well jack dorsey and his beard are out
and there's a new sheriff in town at
twitter and he's not wasting any time
not even a day
new twitter ceo perag arghawal announced
his radical new privacy policy today
when he stepped in as day one of the
king of the blue check marks twitter
announced that somehow sharing images of
people without their consent
public images will no longer be allowed
writing in part quote
let's unpack what this means this policy
update it's always a policy update will
help curb the misuse of media to harass
intimidate and reveal the identities of
private individuals and here's the rub
which disproportionately impacts women
activists
dissidents and members of minority
communities ah now i get the policy
update
it's obvious who this policy is meant to
protect black lives matter
left-wing feminists and pink hats and of
course antifa just for starters
someone sees a video of themselves
looting you better take it down
how about a video torching a store
take it down project veritas catches you
i don't know being honest about your
hatred of conservatives definitely take
it down
not to mention the always protected
elites like hunter biden and
the now suspended maybe conosorta chris
cuomo
no more publishing emails or haunting
photos from the past or text messages
with the assistant to your brother
governor continued justification to keep
censoring hunter's laptop from hell it
no longer matters if the alternate media
contains you know any alternate media
you with a phone covering things that
are happening in public if it contains
information that the public should be
aware of
and say goodbye to the twitter account
twitter accounts like libs of tick tock
you may have seen it it's a humorous
account that takes already publicly
published videos from liberals on tick
tock and repost them on twitter for all
of us to see
the owner can now
have it taken down the liberal who
originally posted it even though they
published it online and should want
millions of people to hear you know
their preferred gender pronouns or the
latest climate hysteria
it gives the social media platform even
more control which is scary more control
about what can be shown and more proof
that they are indeed a publisher and not
simply an unbiased platform we've known
that all along but this new rule shows
us yet again big tech has been censoring
conservatives and trump supporters for a
long time we know that but now
they're coming after you and your phone
and your videos if you catch something
they don't want other people to see
joining me now to break it all down is
missouri senator josh hawley senator
thanks so much you've been all over this
this rule change
what does it mean to you what will it
mean for users of twitter or other
social media and what they can share
well i promise you what it won't mean
that the people whose privacy won't be
protected are normal americans who want
to express their views particularly if
they have conservative views i promise
you that their privacy won't be
respected they'll still get censored
they'll get tracked around let's let's
just remember what twitter does by the
way how they make their money they track
us around the web everywhere they
everywhere we go they collect a dossier
on us they sell our information they
profit off of us i promise you they're
not going to stop doing any of that
stuff and at the end of the day pete
here's the deal the last thing america
needs is another big tech robber baron
who doesn't care anything for free
speech and that's exactly what twitter's
giving us but aren't they just giving
aren't they just saying out loud what
we've known all along whether it's you
know critical race theory in the
classroom called diversity equity
inclusion and we talk about the groups
that are marginalized and therefore need
different protections than everybody
else so
if a certain person points a camera at
somebody that's different than another
certain person and it all depends on
your sexual orientation or your gender
or your race i mean they're just saying
exactly what we know they've been doing
all along
well it's it's that's exactly right and
it's the classic what's become the rule
of the left which is rules for the but
not for me you know they don't follow
their own standards they never do here's
the other thing about twitter it doesn't
really matter what they write down they
don't follow any of the rules anyway
they just make it up as they go along
and the worst part is you can't go to
court to enforce it currently twitter
has immunity so if they violate their
terms of service as to you there's
nothing you can do about it we should
change that you should be able to go and
sue in court and the other thing we
ought to do pete is we ought to break
them up
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else